und der Müller sind eben gesagt sie sind
kein Fachmann für Amokläufe aber sind
schon Fachmann für Cannabis oder würde
ich jetzt mal sagen ich bin schon dran
mit Cannabis natürlich absolute Beratung
Bundesverfassungsgericht bereits im
Jahre
2002 angerufen jetzt habe ich zusammen
mit fünf anderen Richtern angerufen da
liegen Vorlagen die letzte die ich
geschrieben habe gegenüber 140 Seiten es
ist fast eine Dissertation soll ich
jetzt ausführen warum Cannabis
legalisiert werden muss natürlich mache
ich das ja wir haben seit 50 Jahren eine
provisionspolitik die es geschafft hat
Hunderttausende von Menschen in den
Knast zu bringen Millionen von Menschen
wurden mit Geldstrafen übersehen
Einträgen Führungszeugnis Jobverlust und
und und Familien wurden zerstört in
Folge einer Angst die geschaffen wurde
nämlich dadurch dass man seit den 17er
Jahren mit
Theorie ja argumentiert das hat das
Bundesverfassungsgericht im Jahre 1994
bereits widerlegt gleichwohl wird damit
argumentiert und rumgeschmissen
weltweit Vertreters kein Wissenschaftler
und jetzt ich weiß nicht ob ich noch 10
Sekunden habe oder 20 jetzt müssen wir
auf der einen Seite gucken was bringt
die Projektion sie hat nichts gebracht
und das ist auch wissenschaftlicher
Wesen es wird an jeder Ecke gekifft in
jeder Haushalt in jeder
Arme kiffen reiche kiffen Unternehmer
kiffen ja Lehrer kiffen Staatsanwälte
und so weiter jetzt bringt gar nichts
und wenn sie jetzt sehen wie viel Leute
tatsächlich einen Schaden durch Cannabis
dabei bei wie vielen und das wird auch
übertrieben bis zum geht nicht mehr das
sind in etwa und 3.000 die in
stationären Behandlung sind die sind da
aber trotz der projektionspolitik und
dann jeder Jugendliche kann an Strecke
was kriegen und er kriegt gestrecktes
Zeug und es wird teilweise
ungestrecktes Zeug Verkauf und daran
sterben die Jugend weltweit ist ein
Cannabis kein Mensch gestorben das muss
man aber sich vor Augen führen jedes
Jahr in Deutschland 70.000 Tote im Folge
von Alkoholismus und
verfassungsrechtlich noch ergänzend
warum richtet das vorliegt ist der
allgemeine Gleichheitsgrundsatz tangiert
man darf sich tot saufen man darf sich
sogar umbringen nach der neuesten
verfassungsrechtlichen
Rechtsprechung aber wenn sie vor dem
Umbringen ja und das andere scheitert
denn als Versuch ja zwei Gramm Cannabis
rauchen werden sie anschließend bestraft
das ist das gleiche wie Anfang der 90er
Jahre in Londoner wurden sie für den
versuchten für den versuchten Suizid mit
der Todesstrafe bedroht völlig Herr
Müller Ich möchte gerne noch was
ergänzen
ich habe ja eigentlich gehofft dass sie
das heute auch Vorsingen aber das möchte
ich den Zuschauern nicht vor wir zeigen
das Video einmal zu unterschreiben
nein nein nein
nicht Synthese obwohl man nicht
normal kiffen tut nicht weh ein kiffen
ist kaputt
Kriminalisierung sofort
also man kann sagen sie geben für die
endkriminalisierung alles Herr Müller
und wir geben jetzt mal die Frage an
Frau
hält Susanne wie siehst du das mit der
Legalisierung
ehrlich gesagt relativ
leidenschaftslos
also ich es ist ja richtig also Alkohol
ist sehr gefährlich und Alkohol ist
erlaubt und ist vermutlich
gesundheitlich tatsächlich deutlich
schädlicher als als Cannabis auf der
anderen Seite kenne ich natürlich und
wir haben gerade über die Problemgruppe
der Jungs geredet also in diesem in
diesem Alter also Ende Teams anfangs
mehr Jungs würde ich sagen als Mädels
die das Zeug ziemlich intensiv nutzen
und wo ich das Gefühl habe dass es für
ihre Entwicklung jetzt auch nicht so
direkt förderlich ist also sie dann eben
sehr so eine scheißegal Mentalität
entwickeln rumhängen eben ständig alles
sehr entspannt sehen und so weiter was
für ihren weiteren Lebensweg nicht
unbedingt nützlich ist ich weiß nicht
das kann ich auch nicht beurteilen
sozusagen wie gefährlich das ist ich
nehme an das ganze Menge Eltern ganz
froh sind dass sie noch damit
argumentieren können das ist aber nicht
erlaubt also das ist sozusagen eine
gewisse Unterstützung bei den
Diskussionen darüber ist sie haben
natürlich trotzdem recht die Leute
besorgen dass ich trotzdem Sie sie
nutzen ist
trotzdem als Liberaler Mensch versucht
man immer die Eigenverantwortung
hochzuhalten und zu sagen musst ja auch
dafür der Spruch selber ich habe
trotzdem also ich habe letzten Endes
keine Argumente ich habe keinen so
richtig gutes Gefühl bei der Sache weil
ich das ja na ja gute Sache ich ja
selber
eine Frage wäre zum Beispiel also wenn
ich das richtig sehe hat Holland ja eine
relativ liberale Polizei auch Cannabis
immer gemacht hat jetzt aber trotzdem
relativ massive Probleme mit den
drogenmärkten mit anderen Drogen und
also insofern dieses ein Ja oder bzw
also wenn wir das sind wenn wir das
erlauben heißt das aber nicht heißt das
aber nicht sozusagen dass der diese
Drogenmarkt dadurch etwa wegkäme oder
oder überflüssig würde also das ist
zumindest ist anscheinend ja nicht so
das ist ein ganz interessantes Argument
und ich glaube das ist inhaltlich falsch
ist weil es in Holland darf man ganz
kleine Mengen an Cannabis verkaufen das
ist legal und irgendwann große Mengen
verkauft das ist illegal ja wenn ich
jetzt ein Coffeeshop habe wenn in
Amsterdam und ich muss große Mengen
kaufen muss ich mich sozusagen
mit kriminellen Leuten abgeben ja also
ich bin auch total dafür dass man das
legalisiert ich finde es auch gut dass
wir jetzt einen großen
Konsultationsprozess anstoßen dass man
das gesellschaftlich breit auf
aufnimmt der das ist nämlich das eine
wichtige Themen weil wie sie Frau
Gaschke ich kann verstehen dass man sagt
kenne ich nicht und irgendwie neuen muss
es denn sein ja aber als Liberaler
Mensch finde ich muss man sagen es gibt
wirklich keinen Grund zwischen Alkohol
und kiffen Alkohol trinken und kiffen
und dann muss man sagen ja das müssen
wir als freiheitliche Gesellschaft
aushalten können
Frage wenn man sagt naja Alkohol haben
wir erlaubt und jetzt sollten wir das
auch tun Alkohol ist schädlich muss man
da nicht eher sagen vielleicht sollte
man jetzt aufpassen die nächste Droge zu
erlauben
sie jetzt zustimmen allein durch die
Legalisierung würde der Staat jährlich
1,8 Milliarden Euro einnehmen
das sind 4,5 Milliarden ja durch
Einsparung in der Justiz durch Steuern
und und und 4,5
das sind reine Steuer aber sie haben auf
der anderen Seite haben Sie ja die
Möglichkeit ja bei der Polizei
einzusparen wir haben die Möglichkeit
die Leute in den Knästen besser zu
behandeln sie sparen hier und da ein und
das sind nur Anfang Schätzungen sie
schaffen darüber hinaus auch
Arbeitsplätze bereits jetzt sind viele
Arbeitsplätze da im cbd-bereich in
Amerika gibt es ganz legale
Arbeitsplätze da ist ein vernünftiger
Jugendschutz da Ausbildung was da alles
mit einem hergeht und sie schaffen
endlich eine Pflanze auf unseren Boden
Jahrhunderte und Jahrtausende Land
gewachsen ist Cannabis ist ein
wunderbares eine wunderbare Pflanze und
sie könnten Bäume stehen lassen wenn sie
Holz brauchen machen
Sie denn lieber als sie Alkohol trinken
wenn ich dürfte natürlich im Zweifel
nein ich bin mittelstands-trinker ich
trinke wie wir alle
Flasche zu dem zu dem Argument
einstiegsdrom ich nicht mehr drüber
diskutieren wenn das höchste deutsche
Verfassungsgericht bereits 1994 das
kommt aus der Zeit aus unserer Zeit
Christiane F Christiane F ist am Bahnhof
so rum gerannt und hat wie viele andere
Leute auch vorher gekifft aber andere
Leute haben auch vor der Muttermilch
genossen Schokolade gegessen Zucker im
über den Maß und so weiter diese
einstiegsdrohung Theorie ist nicht mehr
haltbar und sie führt dazu dass da freue
ich mich die führt so ein bisschen dazu
dass sie haltbar ist also es ist mir
Entschuldigung haben sie einen
Wissenschaftler weltweit selbst die
Menschen die gegen eine Cannabis
Legalisierung sind sagen nicht mehr
Einstiegsdroge
die haben wir die haben wir wir haben
Leute die habe ich auch in meinem
Jugendgericht ja die Kissen zu viel aber
ich habe auch ganz viele Leute in meinem
Jugendgericht die saufen zu viel und
wenn dem so ist dann kiffen die ja zu
viel obwohl wir eine prohibitionspolitik
haben und da hätte ich in meinen 30
Jahren Jugend Richter tun ganz oft mit
den Jungs sprechen wollen und zwar offen
und ehrlich wie viel kiffst du warum
kiffst du ist das richtig für dich und
so weiter das konnte ich nicht und das
können auch Eltern heute noch nicht weil
der ja immer diese Schwerter hängt ja
das ist strafbar das ist das
interessiert die Jugendlichen überhaupt
nicht ob es strafbar ist im Gegenteil es
macht die Sache noch viel spannender ich
könnte ja weiter wir müssen mich auch
unterbrechen sonst übernehme
nicht aber ich bin sehr beeindruckt von
ihrem Enthusiasmus für das Gras wenn sie
selber gar nicht konsumieren eigentlich
ins Ausland fahren das Konsumieren
wissen Sie denn dann überhaupt die
Wirkung natürlich war ja auch jung und
zwar bin ich ja bis 34 nicht Richter
gewesen ja
und will natürlich habe ich gekifft in
meiner Schule haben alle gekifft das
sind heute Unternehmer Staatsanwälte das
sind alles Mögliche für den Erfolg
finden Sie nein das ist provozieren aber
wir machen das doch weiter so okay das
führt ja auch zu was ja warum ich mich
engagiere das sage ich Ihnen mein Vater
hat sich tot gesoffen mit diesen ganzen
Geschichten die da drumherum sind die
brauche ich nicht ausfüllen ja brauche
ich nicht mein Bruder hat
vielleicht gekifft weil einer
kifferszene war 15 Jahre 16 Jahre ja den
hat man stigmatisiert kriminalisiert und
schließlich in den Knast gebracht so und
dann frage ich mich ja hätte man meinen
Vater nicht in den Knast bringen müssen
weil er säuft nein weil mein Bruder in
den Knast gebracht weil wir ja einen
Schützenfest mental ich bin übrigens
Mitglied von zwei Schützen Fragen ja
Betäubungsmittel aber es ist auch eine
Allheilmittel für viele vor 5000 Jahren
haben das die alten Chinesen benutzt
heutzutage haben 100.000 Menschen
Cannabis als Rezept bevor sie 45 Jahre
durften sie es noch nicht mal als Rezept
haben Unterbrechung gebeten deswegen
würde ich gerne meine Müller fragen wenn
es jetzt legal wäre würden sie gemeinsam
mit Herr Müller kiffen
die Zeit also 16 17 ich denke wir haben
alle gekifft und
natürlich das Problem das Problem was
sie gar nicht ansprechen ist und das
habe ich gelesen die Risiken also
medizinische Risiken habe ich gelesen
sind doch da nichts unterschätzen also
eine Sache
Prostatakrebs wird beeinflusst durch
Cannabiskonsum warum wer warum
nehmen Sie das nicht zu erkennen oder
wollen sie das nicht zur Kenntnis nehmen
und ist das für sie nicht wichtig also
ich denke da kann man nicht drüber weg
singen alles wird irgendwie beeinflusst
durch irgendwas wenn Sie zu viel Zucker
essen wird es möglicherweise dazu führen
dass sie irgendwie zu dick wird wenn sie
dies oder jenes machen wird das auch
jedes Maß bei Jugendlichen
ja das wird auch so gesagt nun habe ich
aber in meiner Schulklasse waren bald
alle am Kiffen und die sind heute
Beispiele
es geht immer mehr Erziehung und dass
wir uns also beim bei mir und war das
früher so es gab diese kifferszene und
die Trinks sehen ja und das ist
eigentlich schlecht ja und wir müssen
und die und die Kinder die gekifft haben
die Jugendlichen Jugendlichen waren es
ähm die haben dann morgens vor der
Schule angefangen zu kiffen ja und da
muss man eigentlich den Leuten sagen zu
kiffen ist wie wenn man viel Alkohol
trinkt ja das ist beides Drogenkonsum
das machen beides Betäubungsmittel das
ist beides ernst zu nehmen ja ich kann
noch nicht betrunken in die Schule gehen
ich kann nicht bekifft in die Schule
gehen ja dass man ab und an vielleicht
einmal die Woche ein bisschen mehr
trinkt oder noch kifft so sollten wir
das glaube ich verankern und beibringen
dass das so benutzt wird und dann sollen
die Leute auch nicht zu irgendeinem
Dealer gehen der ihn dann irgendwann mal
gestrecktes Zeug oder anderes Zeug gibt
sondern das soll man genauso kaufen wie
eine vernünftige Flasche als Juristen
sind hier für das wir sind ja auch immer
auf dem Boden des Grundgesetzes davon
abgesehen ja ich habe ein Eid geschworen
ich darf noch ein Wort dazu erstmal
Danke Schön ja so ich wir haben bekifft
in der Schule gesessen und Lehrer haben
die haben sich nicht getraut uns
rauszuschmeißen weil sie Angst davor
hatten dass diese von ihnen geliebten
Schüler möglicherweise ein
Strafverfahren bekommen das und das
haben sie gerade schön da geht natürlich
gibt es Probleme bei dem einen oder
anderen aber diese Probleme sind im
Verhältnis zu der zu den Problemen die
durch die Prohibition wir gekommen sind
weltweit übrigens Millionen von Toten
durch Kriege und und und und der Kampf
gegen die Droge ausgerufen von Richard
Nixon ja
1968 der ist lange verloren und wenn Sie
das ins Verhältnis setzen ist es so
ähnlich wie ja natürlich ist es Herr
Müller wollen wir jetzt noch mal eine
Frage Wagen ob sie Frau Gaschke jetzt
komplett überzeugt haben schon nachdem
ich wirklich feurig gehalten immer ich
habe mal mit dem CSU Müller
wunderbarer Mann
entwicklungsentwicklungsminister zehn
Jahre der dabei Lanz gehabt am Schlag am
Schluss sagte er jetzt bin ich 49% dafür
ja für die Legalisierung dann habe ich
gesagt die 51 Prozent sind der CSU
geschuldet also ich kann Ihnen eine
Sache sagen ich bin total gegen die
Legalisierung auch jetzt noch aber es
hat noch nie ein Gast bei 8:15 Uhr so
vehement ein Thema vorgestellt
werden sie in der nächsten Sendung
erklären ich habe meine Meinung geändert
das höre ich ganz ganz oft und das
werden sie auch noch machen ich brauche
für Zeiss ihn wenn sie nämlich demnächst
mal treffen